he is definitely not welcomed in our
country he is war criminal and he can
print the war to Belarus we don't want
this uh Prego will not likely come alone
but with his mercenaries with his stats
for them neither Belarus or Ukraine
should exist so proportion might be
involved in military training I don't
know trade of arms it's not excluded
that precaution could be involved in
another tech on Ukraine from Belarus
territory
but also it creates more
danger to our neighbors Lithuania Poland
and other countries but of course nobody
wants progression to be in Belarus but
we will of course watch closely what
will be the next now for version
disappeared we don't know we our
information is limited